hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday
what is it September 24th 2018 what's
going on how are ya I just realized my
fly's down am I at that age now 50 years
old I mean that guy walking around
doesn't always flies down my glasses
I still haven't fixed this all I do is
just [ __ ] about this wire rather than
going out and forgetting it fixed why
would you do that bill alright I just
flew back from Charleston South Carolina
for nine I was in Richmond for a dozen
knock no [ __ ] no [ __ ] Virginia I was
down in the [ __ ] South had a great
time had a goddamn great time I got to
tell you some Richmond Virginia the
Altria Theater top five top five
theaters in America I've ever played at
there was the I don't know if I don't
know what it was the whole layout of it
that dome above how great the sound was
the crowd was amazing it was incredible
you know now I know what she's all what
about us didn't know [ __ ] a great time
they're two great crowds the whole
[ __ ] time great people they didn't
lose their houses because of the
hurricane I haven't been to [ __ ]
North Carolina yet you know I was so
relieved then when I got to Charleston
because they said the thing was gonna
hit him dead center you know and I was
like what am I gonna show up everybody
lost their house I'm gonna come down
there being like oh what's up with this
[ __ ] wire on my part you like
bitching about that people just launched
the house I didn't want that I was so
relieved so relieved that I didn't have
to go to design a ver send me to a
disaster area I am much better hundreds
if not thousands of miles away doing a
benefit where the money is then sent to
that area you get me in the area my act
my act does not work when people are
knee-deep in water in their living room
it just doesn't okay I've tried
doesn't work and it's just you know it's
just not a good thing but you know it's
you know there's other comments for that
it's a great big beautiful [ __ ] world
of comedy
anyways I flew back today and guess
who's sitting next to me on the plane
Frankie Valli I couldn't believe it I
was freaking out this guy I like
I didn't bug him he was literally right
next to me and his whole vibe was he
didn't want to be bugged so I did not
[ __ ] I didn't say one [ __ ] word to
him other than excuse me because I had
the window you know and the guy's like
84 years old you should seen him popping
up out of his seat the end of the flight
to grab his bag you know I we expecting
someone to bug him and uh incredible
shape kept himself in like he [ __ ]
weighs the exact same he weighed back
when he was singing all those songs it's
very inspiring actually when I looked
him up one of the questions that people
asked what you know I like all the top
questions long one was how did Frankie
Valli die you know that's when you know
you crushed it in life you've been
living so long people just assume that
you're dead I don't know I was pretty
impressed by that I hope I live that
long when did Bill burr die uh he's
still alive you can go see him down at
the [ __ ] Hukilau in Chicopee
Massachusetts all right what's your
favorite Frankie Valli song what - mine
is that remember that song yeah my
Georgia though I never laid a hand on
you my eyes adored you like it's
something in itself he couldn't see if I
got better I adored you're so close so
close and yet so far he sat next to me
on the plane I didn't [ __ ] say [ __ ]
to him he does that you know he I was it
was enough
was enough he was [ __ ] automated oh
did you only know really big fan great
now he has to go wash his hand it's a PC
you know [ __ ] Lehman AMA sailing
straight that was his mood today I'm
talking like I know the guy I did SEC
next sit next to him for like [ __ ]
three hours what I would have done if I
just started singing his [ __ ] so if I
was you know I just put on my [ __ ]
headphones I just started singing his
[ __ ] songs she sang like nine million
[ __ ] times then he has to hear him
disgustingly out of tune
probably elbowed me hey kid shut up I
did it better or something you know
something cool something that a cool old
guy would say man I hope I'm in the
shape piece I hope I live that long and
I hope I'm in the shape he's in he
looked [ __ ] great and what I care he
still sings his ass off so that was
pretty cool I'll tell you what wasn't
cool I'll tell you what I didn't enjoy
was how the New England Patriots got
their asses where by a bunch of goddamn
nerds Oh
this happens every September every
September we start off slow and then
everybody has us dead and buried it's
[ __ ] over every set in the new
tradition in the AFC is in September the
Patriots are done and Kansas City's
going to the Super Bowl how many times
well Bill it's only the second year in a
row
can't you see it's over it's a gift wrap
it up in a [ __ ] bow right [ __ ]
unbeliev [ __ ] virzi man virzi jinxed
me he [ __ ] tease the Patriots I
didn't even give him [ __ ] that's the
second week in a row
that he's lost on the Lions as he calls
them the hapless lions [ __ ]
unbelievable not as unbelievable as this
goddamn [ __ ] wire oh did I move my
head oh is this a comfortable position
now go [ __ ] yourself
I I was actually doing I did two shows
last night my wife taped the game so I
haven't even seen it but I was watching
just the ticker on my phone cuz I you
guys you [ __ ] download the app and
then you gotta have your pet how do you
keep all your passwords well how do you
keep how do you keep track of them
you know unless you just don't give a
[ __ ] and you just use the same one every
goddamn time I'm not even good at coming
up with passwords like when I go to type
it in that that the computers like weak
yeah that's getting better and I'm like
[ __ ] zebra [ __ ] 98 they're like fair
it's like how the [ __ ] is somebody gonna
figure that out
anyways umm balloon herpe 49 weak like
this does somebody already have that I
have no idea but let me ask you this
when was the last [ __ ] time he's a
goddamn stats for stats or stat he's a
[ __ ] stat for you when was a question
I had when was the last time the Browns
the Lions and the Buffalo Bills all one
in the same week Jesus Christ I mean
you're talking the Browns in the Lions
have both gone Owen 16 in this decade
right was it this decade on the years of
flying by 32 [ __ ] losses you know
they always do that when they talk about
the national debt and they try to put it
in terms that you can understand I'm
gonna put 32 losses in terms that you
can understand lost lost lost lost lost
lost lost lost lost law I'm gonna
[ __ ] do old times 3 plus 2 lost lost
a lot of [ __ ] losses I'm somebody
gonna use that as a ringtone
wah-wah sorry anyways it's weird my team
is 1 & 2 we actually have a worse record
right now than the Cleveland Browns
haven't said that it's kind of [ __ ]
fun
seeing these teams that have sucked so
long be good
I wanted anybody out there call the
Buffalo Bills this week
maybe you bet on about who the [ __ ] who
the [ __ ] our twenty seven nothing
whatever the [ __ ] they were up by
seventeen nothing against the [ __ ]
fight what are the Vikings doing the
Vikings puttin it fans out of out of
their misery early this year they
usually wait to the playoffs playoff um
I watched a bunch of football this
weekend I watched I watched Alabama roll
tad I watched them against the Aggies
loved the Aggies quarterback man that
guy's a [ __ ] gamer he kept a minute
for like a hat almost to the half but I
swear to God watching that watching the
Alabama Crimson Tide it's like watching
the Patriots where the players are so
well coached like the way they turned it
on at the end of the first half to be
like hey let's get another touchdown
here and let's but whatever the hell did
but they were up by like I think I came
up maybe seven let's go in the locker
room up by four they put their foot on
the gas and they went right down the
[ __ ] field and they scored Aggies come
out they shut him down again they got
the ball back and then they kicked a
field goal they tacked on an extra
[ __ ] ten points it was like wait a
minute wait we were down by one score we
down by a touchdown like three minutes
ago we're ready to jog in you know
feeling good about ourselves and all of
a sudden they give me old [ __ ] right
there Fred twice and then the Alabama
was getting the ball coming out I like
halftime and you're like they're gonna
go down they're gonna score another
touchdown [ __ ] game is over
that's essentially what they did and the
fact that Nick Saban I always go to
forget his name and I just remember that
chant when I went to the LSU game and
the whole student section was going [ __ ]
you say bud so I always have to say that
once in my head I have to picture that
memory and then the audio plays [ __ ] you
say Ben I love Nick Nick Saban Nick
Saban the job that that guy is doing
down there considering you know all the
players that you lose every year
everybody thinks they're a pro or that
just a senior
can't play anymore you're just
constantly rebuilding the fact that they
that whatever the hell he instills in
them they get it immediately you know it
was pretty impressive
I missed the LSU game [ __ ] college
football is their games are like on they
have like random games on like Tuesday's
now it seems it's on Friday I think I
missed that but they're three you know I
think we got Florida next week I did say
we I'm in I'm in with [ __ ] LSU I like
you know Kim can't brew for Alabama
they're just too goddamn good right I'm
not looking forward to that Alabama game
that's gonna be rough but who knows
maybe that [ __ ] Cajun Hulk Hogan can
talk them into I don't know I don't know
you know it it'd be funny I got to watch
Alabama every week cuz I never watch
them when they lose how angry does Nick
say I actually worry for his loved ones
when that guy is taking a loss like that
poor Alabama kick every [ __ ] shank two
punts the [ __ ] look on Nick Saban's
face oh my god is like he wanted to rip
the kids [ __ ] foot off anyways I I
hate [ __ ] podcasting when I flew
across the country I could fly I don't
know what it is all my funny just goes
out the window but brain isn't working
[ __ ] sittin here Jesus Christ how was
I gonna talk about I absolutely nothing
to [ __ ] talk about how many minutes
and I'm 12 minutes in 12 [ __ ] minutes
I like I went for you know some tight
come home right I all I want to do is
jump in the shower just wash the [ __ ]
Airport off of me alright can't do it
cuz I own an old house and we got a
plumber in here for the nine millionth
time trying to fix whatever the [ __ ] is
wrong with the toilet this time can't do
it I swear to God
give you guys some advice if you have a
[ __ ] and somebody ever describes a
house is having character I'm telling
you just just head for the hills
all right if you meet a woman and she
says guys find me in timid
just run for the hills there's that
there's a couple of [ __ ] red flags
out there ladies what we write in tell
me what what is it so I can help out
women here what's the what's the red
flag with a guy you don't know him and
he says drink this something creepy I
don't [ __ ] know anyways the Red Sox
clinched that was all exciting until the
Yankees clinched then it's just like oh
so we're both 0 and 0 like what what am
I getting excited about
why is everybody popping [ __ ]
champagne and all that the Indians won
the series I think they took 2 out of 3
from us I'm telling you Terry Francona
and nobody sees this guy people how many
times do I have to be right I'm gonna
Pat myself on the back right now I've
been killing it lately I said it wasn't
[ __ ] open when we slept the Yankees I
was right I said you can't base the
Lions first [ __ ] week on what they're
gonna do or anybody I was right about
that all right I was right about two
things but that feels great to me I feel
like I've been right about a lot of [ __ ]
you know this is what happens when you
get married you know what I mean when
you actually write about something you
just you're gonna tell people so maybe
somebody will give you a [ __ ] and add a
boy every once in a while anyways I well
sorry if wanna [ __ ] die guy
absolutely literally nothing
Charleston football oh yeah yeah this
isn't a [ __ ] sign of global warming
isn't amazing how like sports like they
don't give a [ __ ] they'll talk about war
they'll promote a war and all that [ __ ]
but for some reason global warming or
climate change whatever that is just
completely off limits I have never seen
I never saw a football game called or
delayed because of weather the first
like I don't know 45 years of my life 40
years of my life and now it's like every
other [ __ ] week like the weather is
too bad
to play football which you play no
matter what the weather is so either
somebody sued the [ __ ] out of a stadium
because they just got a perm and it
started to rain at a football game or
we're just getting crazier and crazier
weather you know that's gonna happen
eventually you know because we keep
saving all of these people when Mother
Nature tries to wipe them off the planet
we [ __ ] let everybody know something
is going to happen get out of the
[ __ ] way so she's just gonna have to
start swinging harder and harder and
harder and it's gonna be one of these
[ __ ] times there's gonna be a tornado
that sets down like right in a stadium
and everybody's just gonna go flying
like they went through a like like a
wood chipper you know something if that
[ __ ] guy what the hell is his name
there I always forget his name that guy
the guy he had ALS he was really smart
and he was always predicting negative
[ __ ] I wish he was alive so I could ask
him that it's Steve or something like
that Mike hit one of the regular names
hey Tim Billy Kevin Kevin's a little
that's a little bad for white people
that's a little flavor and your name
back in the day anyways um I would asked
him that a bit hey dude you know not for
nothing what when what year he was like
he was like one of those [ __ ] you
know when you go to like Coney Island or
something he got like the bearded lady
then there's a guy guessing your weight
he was like the guy that guesses your
weight before like super smart people he
was always saying all that crazy [ __ ]
you know in 2038 there's gonna be no
more apples you know he's like he added
down the polar ice caps are gonna
[ __ ] you know just [ __ ] gloom and
doom that guy had you know you guys
think I'm bad that [ __ ] guy Jesus
Christ I would I love to ask the man
been like hey Ricky when is a tornado
gonna [ __ ] set down
in a [ __ ] football stadium that we
don't even see coming he could actually
probably within the [ __ ] week
well actually wait a minute what did
that guy ever predict that came true and
I gotta be honest with a lot of his
predictions they were pretty [ __ ]
obvious it's kind of was saying yeah
we're gonna [ __ ] this whole thing up
which is kind of the direction we're
going in but you know you got to take
like little like happy things that
happen like seeing the Lions the bills
and the Browns all win you know
Bills fans are [ __ ] I've been to two
games out there they're [ __ ] grumpy
[ __ ] you know what I mean they're like
the self they never got over the loss
you know I'm [ __ ] with you
they never got over those Superbowl
losses they're just like it's it's
[ __ ] with them it hangs over that
City it's a great city they're great
people but I'm telling you they put on a
bill shirt I know the feeling believe it
or not back in the day I see it too like
whenever the Red Sox wear that the throw
backs with the Pat Patriot I get lit my
knee my older brother we get sick to our
stomach
when you look at he like oh my god I
don't mind if they ever what they
wearing with the black cleats then it
kind of looks like the original days of
the AFL I don't mind that but if they go
out there with white [ __ ] cleats and
they wear that [ __ ] Pat Patriot
things that's all I think about all I
think about roughing the passer [ __ ]
the the 46 defense Dan Marino lightness
up the Buffalo Bills when they had Jim
Kelly kicking the [ __ ] out of us there
was a minute there where the Jets were
good when they had the New York Stock
Exchange this can't all be football
every week I got people around the world
listening to the [ __ ] and they just
don't give a [ __ ] so I got it at some
point
switch off to something that's going to
be a little bit a little more mainstream
you know I also watched the sorry all I
did was watch football I watch the
[ __ ] Falcons Saints I don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on in the NFC South
but take the over
none of those teams are gonna win [ __ ]
did you see those two [ __ ] guys in
like that 20s couldn't track couldn't
tackle 39 year old Drew Brees
I was that was [ __ ] ridiculous that
if that was a boxing match you'd say it
was fixed let's say right now I don't
know what Matt Ryan's diet is but I want
to be on it that guy he's got to be like
in his 30s now he doesn't that his
[ __ ] face is all taken looks like an
astronaut now those guys always have
nice faces because they spent so many
years out there in the [ __ ] space and
there's like no gravity that's gonna be
like the next thing that rich people do
is everybody else gets poor they're
gonna they're gonna just orbit the Earth
it's really good for your faith it is
gonna be up there just flying around
we're like no gravity you know if you're
rich you get Botox but if you're super
rich you orbit the planet and you're
very young you know wanted to do that
wanted to go to like Mars or something
didn't Lance Bass want to do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] people are out of their mind
don't you know you don't remember when
that teacher went up then you remember
like how much balls it takes to be a
[ __ ] astronaut you're getting on top
of a stick of dynamite you out of your
[ __ ] mind
that's like Chuck Yeager [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] guy in a tollbooth I'll
get in that thing Oh will you I think
it's almost like yeah it's like it's
disrespectful to the other [ __ ]
people you know do they still they put
you in that centrifuge and [ __ ] before
you go on there to make sure you're not
gonna be yakking all the way to the
[ __ ] moon can you imagine that the
first you know the first one the first
one
okay that they send up there with a
bunch of civilians there is going to be
somebody is gonna freak the [ __ ] out and
I guarantee you they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna have something some
sort of some guy just runs down the
island just like puts a syringe right
into your [ __ ] neck so you don't
freak everybody else out when it finally
hits you that you're leaving the planet
there are so many things that scares the
[ __ ] out of me but I gotta admit when
George Clooney just spun off into space
and that [ __ ] movie whatever the hell
it was but he was so nonchalant about it
I didn't care about his character he's
just like oh yeah look at that there's a
serengeti I didn't like it this time of
year and he just floated off
they made him too heroic alright cuz I
don't give a [ __ ] you know how much
balls you have as an astronaut and you
do you have balls the size of my [ __ ]
head which is huge if you don't know who
I am if you've never taken a gander at
it I don't give a [ __ ] who you are you
start slipping off into [ __ ] space
you I don't care how [ __ ] bad-ass you
are either the second you lose your grip
on the space station that you start
floating off and the other people in
there or asleep or some [ __ ] and you're
just that's it you're done there's no
way you just go like well you know I had
a nice run I guess I'm gonna set the
record for being in space you know
you're not gonna say that you're just
gonna be happy like it just [ __ ] gone
that is a [ __ ] lonely ass goddamn
death could I be saying more obvious
[ __ ] oh is it built to slip off into the
[ __ ] space by yourself now what
happens when you're up there cuz I know
like some [ __ ] eggheads figured out
why can't I complement them you know
some guy who's way smarter than I am
somehow figured out that when you went
to space because you were outside of the
atmosphere the sun's rays would be so
goddamn hot your saliva would reach the
boiling point in your [ __ ] mouth
I remember that Red Bull guy when he
jumped that was a problem like if his
mask came off within I don't know how
many seconds like his his he would lend
he would go from like hurtling through
the atmosphere with boiling water in
your mouth I mean you might as well get
shot right directly up your [ __ ] with
lightning at that point to just make the
trifecta of horror hey remember the hole
in the ozone layer how come they never
[ __ ] talk about that anymore is that
thing gonna do they fix it oh my god I
actually came up with an idea for a
[ __ ] movie that I think you could
make a trilogy out of and it's so
ridiculous I'm actually rather than just
saying it or doing a [ __ ] bit about
it
I actually just registered and it
registered it at the [ __ ] writers
guild on the way from the airport popped
in there really quick and just [ __ ]
knocked it out it's so coming up with a
sci-fi movie right now yeah for some
reason it's just really easy because I
feel like we're we're we're there you
know just all this [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
coming out all this [ __ ] that we're
[ __ ] up you know 60 years ago you had
to use your imagination you know ray
guns and [ __ ] pocket doors that
opened up with the heat of your [ __ ]
body whatever happened on Star Trek
right teleporting and all of that [ __ ]
yeah and I like to use your [ __ ]
imagination now it's just like you know
we're skyping with each other Matt's
like [ __ ] they did on Star Trek so I
don't think it's that hard now well
actually you got to be ahead of the game
right you know I got on a limit I would
say this script is gonna suck I'm
probably gonna need some help with it
you know funny would be a bike she made
like a killer [ __ ] trilogy of sci-fi
[ __ ] movies and then every other year
when the movie came out I'd have to go
to like [ __ ] Comic Con that thing
that I've made fun of so many [ __ ]
times I actually went to it this year I
had a great time people were actually
cool you know it's just fun I don't know
what it is isn't it fun to just makes
fun of [ __ ] that everybody likes
everybody gets all excited about
something and you just get to be a [ __ ]
tickets are on sale for the all things
comedy festival by the way we were
trending today in all the The Hollywood
Reporter variety and all that this
company all things comedy than I am a
small part of we signed a deal with
Comedy Central to do four one-hour
specials the first one being mr. Paul
Varzi then we're gonna do three other
killer ones for them next year we got
some stuff in the works was slowly
becoming a little [ __ ] entity here
you know all freckles he's building his
own little kiosk out here that's how I
view this business I view it like a
giant [ __ ] mall and I got this little
store right in the middle you know this
one's you walk by the guy is a little
helicopter things that fly you know
ourselves keychains
that's me ain't [ __ ] with Lord and
Taylor
anyways plowing ahead here let me let me
read uh some of the the advertisement
the adverts there was something I wanted
to go off on but I'm not gonna [ __ ]
I'm not gonna [ __ ] throw them I would
just say this you know I can't [ __ ]
say you can't [ __ ] say anything
anymore
he just gets [ __ ] get in trouble you
know there was a certain somebody on a
certain something that was telling
people what they should or shouldn't be
[ __ ] saying in the same business that
this person was in it was just like well
you know are you advocating
censorship this is such a weird [ __ ]
these are lefties lefties um anyways is
there anything worse than okay when
somebody does that there should be an
app you know that if you ever Satan Kate
likes Excel I don't know we're just a
giant like one of those Hulk hands but
it's like padded just [ __ ] punches
you right in the face you should never
say that to another human being okay
bookie my unless you're doing the voice
on South Park okay
my bookie everybody you know ever since
I started this podcast people have been
asking me for advice ask me what team to
bet on the truth is I don't know who's
gonna win certainly not this [ __ ]
year but if you think you know you gotta
check out my bookie remember who you're
betting on is just as important as who
you're betting with that's a little
brain teaser there that's why I'm
telling you to bet with my bookie that's
not why it's cuz they're paying me to
tell you that trust me guys they're
paying me they are your best bet this
season they've been in business for
years they have great reviews online
that's a biggie degenerate gamblers
usually don't give good reviews they got
good reviews online great reviews sorry
and their mobile site is easy to use my
bookie you win they pay you lose you
know that you pay yeah depending how far
you take it you might have to engage in
a sexual act that you never thought you
dope they have in game live betting the
most rewarding player perks in the
business and for you fantasy fantasy
guys out there you can even bet on the
over-under on how many fantasy points a
player will score each game my bookie is
slammed with new betters and wants to
give everyone the best service possible
if you are willing to deposit after 7:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time they will
give you an additional $25 free free to
play on deposits over a hundred bucks
that's pretty cool huh join now and my
bookie will match
deposit dollar-for-dollar use promo code
burr to activate the offer visit my
bookie online today that's my B oh okay
ie and don't forget to use promo code
ber bu are are when creating your
account to claim up to $1,000 in free
play and now if you're willing to hold
out until 7:00 p.m. like I just said to
[ __ ] sentences ago you can get an
extra $25 free play by using pro promo
code Byrd 25 what you just said when you
claim when your account to claim up to a
thousand no no no it's not about a
hundred bucks on deposits over a hundred
dollars all right you got a deposit on a
bucks to get the 25 and do it after 7:00
p.m. it's up to you guys it's up to you
but I would wait until after dinner and
take the extra money you play you win
you get paid alright simply safe
everybody simply safe home security is
home security that finally gets it right
well what are the other ones doing taken
out the homeowner simply safe started
ten years ago with the mission to fix
the industry they cut out contracts
middleman and pushy sales guys they made
it easy to set up your system with no
hard wiring or tools with simply safe
you get professionally monitored 24/7
protection for just fifteen dollars a
month that's your home protected by
police dispatch and fire dispatch also
known as everyone loves this system they
love how it works and how easy it is to
use today simply say protects over two
million people they've one editor Choice
Awards from CN et PC Magazine and wire
cutter those are going to be three the
nerdiest [ __ ] magazines I've ever
heard so you know that good go to simply
safer comm today to order your simply
safe system you get a sixty day
risk-free trial that's simply safe si MP
Li si fe bird comm simply safe bird calm
[Music]
look who's back everybody but who do me
undies be undies the hurricane hit North
Carolina doo doo doo doo me undies me
undies hit him in the [ __ ] vagina now
they're up to the knees in tobacco and
water if your underwears wet then you
oughta get sorry get some [ __ ] me
undies but I Betty Boop me undies like
the [ __ ] Red Cross after those
[ __ ] things you give it to the Red
Cross
you know boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boo
boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boo
I was at the Red Cross no that was um
mash me undies everybody you've heard me
obsess over mind me undies evidently you
heard me talk about how they are three
times softer than cotton I never said
that and come with fun with new prints
each month oh yeah I've definitely
talked about that they do have fun new
prints every month three times softer
than cotton I don't know I have no idea
I just know my junks happy okay well my
junks happy I get a little spring in my
step
kiss my wife on the cheek it puts
everybody in a good mood you know if I
wear regular underwear Nixie know I'm
slapping the parakeet everything's
[ __ ] it's just off in the house I
[ __ ] hate people they don't Birds you
know what I mean it's not bad to own a
dog thing's [ __ ] stupid whether you
go out there in the world you know you
can't let the [ __ ] thing out it's too
dumb you took all the wolf out of it
right you have a cat cats [ __ ]
annoying you know I mean comes and goes
like a hooker shits all over the house
but I understand keeping that thing but
a [ __ ] bird man it's supposed to be
out there flying around okay you got the
thing sitting and a god there's
something about a bird in a [ __ ] cage
it makes me just wait I gotta finish
this copy it really bothers me then I
would never slap a parakeet
right I'd flick it right in its [ __ ]
beak but I've got a big scoop that I'm
so excited to share with you evidently
me undies just gave their membership a
massive upgrade members will also pay
less for everything on the me undies
website with special member pricing that
means if you want a second pair of me
undies a bralette or lounge pants hey
ladies are you doing you'll pay less
than anyone else the membership comes
with no strings attached
you can switch styles skipped a month or
cancel at any time they come with a 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you don't love
them just send them back for a full
refund me undies me undies has a great
offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers when you purchase
any me undies you can get 15% off and
free shipping that's a no-brainer
get 15% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
to get your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
dot-com / / that's me undies dot-com / /
you don't [ __ ] commercials I hate
whatever that cheap-ass underwear is
that they show on TV with that phat
construction worker you know what I mean
they're always like no no sweat no it's
like tochi's it's the most disgusting
description ever it's like dude your
problem is not your underwear your
problem is you're a fat [ __ ] that's what
the problem is and there's no wonder
we're out there that's gonna solve that
all right eat a [ __ ] salad sorry but
you know God bless that company they saw
neat they're like you know there's a lot
of fat people up there they got they got
I got underwear riding up their asses
while they're driving their rigs I'm
gonna make underwear for them anyway
stamps calm the US Postal Service is an
important tool for any business stamps
comb is the easiest way to access all
the amazing services of the post office
stamps com never closes like that easy
check up the street or [ __ ] licks in
print postage for letters or packages at
your convenience 24/7 print postage
frame mail class right from your own
computer
in print official US postage for any
letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer in printer
they'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates exact postage
this is my professional voice stamps.com
will even help you decide the best class
of mail based on your needs no need to
lease an expensive postage meter and
there are no long-term commitments I use
stamps comm whenever I'm sending out my
[ __ ] posters I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure it out so can you and right now
you can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage a digital
scale go to Stan's comm click on the
microphone stop the homepage and type in
brr-brr that stamps comm enter ber bam
all right that's it for [ __ ] that now
evidently we go into the we go into the
questions here for the week for the week
moto gp hey Bill I haven't heard you
talk about the guy in the MotoGP moto2
gripped the other guy other racers
breaks in the middle of the race how the
[ __ ] did he do that maybe I had my
headphones out while some [ __ ] had I
work with felt it necessary to tell me
about his weekend I don't give a [ __ ]
about but would love to hear your
thoughts on the incident I got a I gotta
check this out
there we go let's search here moto moto
moto [ __ ] GP moto gp breaks oh break
grab there it is let's see what we got
you know what I was just singing that do
you member super fuzz that movie and
then they were in the transition between
one scene to another they had the
background singers they go super super
super super super alright yeah did this
guy get banned for life you could
[ __ ] kill somebody doing that the
caption literally says the guy's going
like he wanted to kill me alright and I
have to sit through a [ __ ] ad oh and
of course here we go your ad will play
your video will play after this ad
remember the internet when it didn't
have a bunch of ads you know that was a
great [ __ ] time now they just they
just punt
I mean it's not as bad as listening to
me read ads and you always have the
option of fast-forwarding through mine
these [ __ ] [ __ ] won't let me do
it come on I want to see it I want to
see it alright this is gonna take too
long unfortunately but this [ __ ] guy
grabbed onto his I don't want your
[ __ ] channels [ __ ] leave me alone you
know noise the [ __ ] out of me when
you're on the plane and then in the they
shut off your movie to do a goddamn
commercial but some who [ __ ] is gonna
sign up for a credit card sixty thousand
free air miles that's enough to get you
from here to Chile and back they say all
this dumb [ __ ] it's like yeah but you're
not gonna let me do it so what's the
difference right I'll only be able to
use these during like like the winter
months you'll let me fly to [ __ ]
Alaska when it's pitch-black out all
right evidently this [ __ ] grabbed this
guy's [ __ ] brakes what happened I
don't want to blame the victim but what
in God's name did this guy do moto gp
grape break grab I just have to let me
just read about it here MotoGP rider
grabs competitors brake at 140 miles an
hour this guy should be arrested how the
[ __ ] did he think that no one was gonna
see this does he realize it's televised
oh my god what a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
like right out of Wrestlemania and then
the ref didn't see it holy [ __ ] without
like that guy's an amazing writer now
that was his front brake too well I
guess they always use the front brake
it's the back brake you don't use I
don't know [ __ ] about motorcycles
alright disgraced moto to Ryder row
monofin ah do the Italian ah Jesus do
you know what this finally no mob shows
on TV they would turn in their [ __ ]
reputation around and this guy's he's
got to go full soprano on him the guy
deservedly lost his spot
the Marinelli snipers team all they
kicked him off the team after you
attempted one of the more dangerous
stunts we'll see in competitive racing
ah man he's 22 years old he's a [ __ ]
hothead he just ruined his career
boy as Finetti rode beside competitors
Stefano Monsey I wonder if there's any
history between these two families you
never know
kidding at the san marino GP the 22 year
old reached out and grabbed Nancy's
break at a hundred and forty miles an
hour
luckily Manzi didn't fall off his bike
and finet ease is it fine at ease antics
were completely uncalled for that's one
of the worst sentences
luckily Manzi didn't fall off his bike
oh as finales antics were completely
uncalled for Fornetti was shown the
Black Flag and disqualified from the
race for attempting to harm an opponent
while he was banned for two races and
fired from his team fnatic thought the
penalty was unfair still he added that
he had no plans to race again what Wow
the world is that world is closed to me
I'll not race anymore he said an
interview he granted to the la república
it isn't my world there's there's too
much injustice I was wrong that is true
but nobody cares about my pain I wasn't
a real man I was unable to control my
anger but man Z could have killed me too
well what happened before that dude I'm
telling this is why you have to get into
racing it's like the Real Housewives for
Men these [ __ ] guys like how mad they
[ __ ] get it each other than the petty
[ __ ] that's not really petty but like
Days of Thunder all of that you watch
that movie you like Alice okay this is
[ __ ] silly like that [ __ ] really goes
down I guess it's better in a car cuz
you can [ __ ] slam into people it's
you know for some reason that's not
considered attempted murder Wow
I guess maybe because I have a temper I
feel bad for that guy or also maybe
because I I went after a dream and made
it come true and that kid did too and he
just [ __ ] up his dream I actually on
some level feel bad for him that he's
maybe he was just emotional after the
[ __ ] race and just said I'm done you
know I hope it just wasn't coz he just
couldn't beat the guy the guy was always
getting the best of him you know any
week pulled like a Bill Laimbeer you
like those players well you're better
than me so I'm just gonna wait till you
leave your feet and I'm just gonna take
your [ __ ] legs out that's still are
my favorite things of all time Bill
Laimbeer saying we tried to play a mind
game it's late you don't like like there
was a lot of layers to that it's like no
you're just out there hurting people
all right football in pizza oh my god oh
Jesus Christ
[Music]
hey yo Billy colorless Cavs there's
never been a truer statement my legs are
sweating that they are the color of milk
I'm happy you're enjoying getting in
shape most people don't get past the
first week of eating eating well and and
it's a shame because it all it takes is
one good week of clean food and breaking
a sweat well not I feel like a hundred
pounds overweight but I don't want you
mean he said I started doing
long-distance biking in my 20s you know
what's hilarious I just had my bike
fixed up I bought a bike in 1983 that I
still have I bought a 12 speed with my
paper route money that was 15 years old
and I quit the my paper route the year
before I think I don't think no I don't
think I did I went from having a paper
route to have an apart time job I do
remember that I had a paper from third
grade to ninth grade and then I had to
sign a form or something because I was
too young to work Arnel then I started
caddying I was a caddy for a while did
that feel like
the [ __ ] year or something then I
just started I always had a job it was
great I always had money the worst
[ __ ] thing in the world now is that
little boys and girls they can't be paid
they can't be paper boys and girls
anymore it was the [ __ ] best he
didn't have to hit your parents up for
my just I had [ __ ] money do you
understand that I was making like 8 9 10
bucks a week when I was in third grade I
mean I was stuffing it in the walls I
had like no overhead I mean I what the
[ __ ] was I gonna spend it on football
cards that's what I spent it on and I
had a little Bank and I just stuffed it
in there and anytime I wanted something
if I wanted to I used to like I had a
job and I was so young that when I had a
job I would buy toys with it i buy
football cards and candy soda and all
that [ __ ] I just was [ __ ] great ever
one time I rode my bike all the way to
[ __ ] McDonald's
but the buddy of mine we both lied to
our parents we were riding down a
[ __ ] two-lane highway nobody reported
us because there was no phones
you know we drove all the way down there
and when it was the coolest [ __ ]
thing I bet our parents had no [ __ ]
idea I was exhausted because it was one
town over and I just had this little
piece of [ __ ] red Coster bike and then
when I got older I thought I had the
Raleigh Beach Rambler I remember I
pointed the bike cuz I thought it looked
[ __ ] stupid because I hadn't
white-walled tires on it and I pointed
on it and laughed and my dad was like I
like that you like that and I was afraid
of him so I just said yeah bought this
bike it in like and then everybody made
fun of me of these giant pee-wee Herman
[ __ ] tires on it but then one day you
know we were riding down the hill and
everyone was slamming on the brakes like
that's what you did for fun to see you
look sort of skidmark you could leave
the tires was so [ __ ] big everybody
else has just went like that when mine
skid it actually sounded like a car when
and everybody thought it was cool but it
had the big fat ass [ __ ] seat on it
but I had a paper oon it [ __ ] snowed
out and you know rain sleet or snow you
had to deliver the paper and mine I
delivered the Herald and then I
delivered the Boston Globe and I
remember the kid down the street he had
the he had the coveted route there was
used to be this paper called the Patriot
Ledger and it was an afternoon paper
that makes any [ __ ] sense and it
reported on I guess I don't know what
the stories that the other papers
already reported on how they had
advanced over the last I don't know how
many hours whatever so anyways he had it
and it was a Monday through Friday
[ __ ] route and it was like that thing
was with the holy grail of paper routes
in my neighborhood and the oldest
brother got it and he passed it on to
his next brother it's it stayed they had
like three boys and they all had the
[ __ ] route and the youngest kid was
my age so there was no way to ever get
the [ __ ] paper route so we had the
globe Herald first then the Boston Globe
and that thing was seven days a week 365
and I had from third grade - yeah
ninth grade and I don't think I haven't
missed a day unless look I had a
ruptured appendix I missed a couple
weeks that time and we took a family
trip one time when I was a kid and I
remember it sucked you'd come back
these [ __ ] [ __ ] adults would do
your route and it just you know I said
put it in the door it was always dry
they would put a [ __ ] rubber band
around it an elastic whatever the [ __ ]
you call it and they would just drive
down the street and [ __ ] throw it you
get all these complaints and everyone
get mad at you and all this [ __ ] so
anyways I ended I saved up my money and
I bought that you know Vega nuovo sport
right really nice [ __ ] bike and I
don't know my parents never threw it out
and I came home one day in my 30s and I
saw it I was like I'm gonna [ __ ] take
that thing alright because and you just
you know represent something to me
working hard you know that if you work
hard you get stuff right so I [ __ ]
got that thing and it was all like
originals and all that [ __ ] and I just
it just [ __ ] finally died on me from
years of [ __ ] ridin and stuff and I
decided our guest sitting in my parent's
garage I decided that I was gonna fix it
up and I finally brought it over to
somebody it literally cost me almost the
same amount of money that the bike cost
me in like 1983 when I bought it and I
want to get back to riding I just had to
find where you can ride in LA that's
like safe I know out in Santa Monica you
can and [ __ ] I don't know maybe some
of the parks along the LA River but I
always feel like you're gonna meet some
[ __ ] serial killer down there you
know we're gonna attack by a [ __ ]
mountain lion Pelley's a weird place so
anyways let me get back and I used to
ride that thing when I got when I got
old when I was 21 I got in the best
shape of my [ __ ] life a t-shape you
know so no squats but what I did four
legs was I rode the bike and I used to
ride 11 miles every day Monday through
Friday after working in a warehouse
that's how young I was I had the energy
to do that and on the weekends I would
ride 18 miles and I would take one
[ __ ] day off needless to say I won't
be doing that again I'll [ __ ] take a
little 5 mile jaunt on let one [ __ ]
level land alright sorry that was in my
entire history with bicycles bikes used
to be a big [ __ ] deal by the way I
don't think they're big deals to kids
anymore it was freedom he just [ __ ]
left he'd find other kids he just
[ __ ] rode around did [ __ ] you know I
don't know I started doing long-distance
biking he said in my 20s I was never in
bad shape but I certainly wasn't in as
good a shape as I am now having said all
that I really hope that once this year
you are able to order herself a pizza
crack open a high life and watch nine
hours of football yeah that sounds
perfect he said not of the hypothetical
what would you be will be your
combination of pizza and beer for that
occasion I go with a local joint here in
Massachusetts originally from Cleveland
Browns congratulations on your victory
said Anna Killians Irish red a beer that
no one drinks anymore but it's delicious
I gotta be honest with you I am I am may
I am white trash when it comes to beer
if I could find it you know what I would
do the first beer I ever got drunk off
of was Michelob light and my pizza spot
was in Stoughton Massachusetts the town
spa so I'd have one of their pizzas I've
out of a plain one extra crispy whatever
they do you know well done and I would
have a Michelob light and I'd have it in
one of those giant [ __ ] goblets that
they used to have at the end of the
Miller Lite commercials les villain no
was it less filling tastes great that's
right that's what I would do New York my
pizza spot I haven't lived there a long
time the pizza place used to go to was
right right next to danger fields
because I always end in that spot and I
would go it was sudden pizza I think it
was called I always thought that they
had a nice sauce and the cheese was on
in a complimented the sauce rather than
destroying even being able to taste that
there was any sort of sauce there but I
know there's a bunch of you know I
haven't lived there in like [ __ ] 11
years so I have no idea what everybody
like that Joe's pizza down the village
was a big one but I don't know I like
that that sudden pizza man I [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] all right old podcast
question dear Billy been doing it
forever
I was listening to a throwback on the
Thursday podcast great taste in music by
the way that's Andrew yeah that's his
taste in music if you listen to mine it
would just be like yeah be bunch of hair
metal and I was wondering if your
feelings have changed on downloading
music and movies illegally you were
ranting on enterin how terrible it is
and I'm too young to remember that
controversy I'm 20 but you had me
convinced it was certainly illegal and
not cool I don't know if it was ever
illegal what happened was the techno
ecology came about that you could do it
anyways I said something said he had
naps my friend said he had nap sure in
high school and everyone did maybe he
said your older brother he left out that
word I guess it's like looking at celeb
leaked to celebrity nude photos
yeah it's wrong but who doesn't want to
get a glimpse of that I never look at
those [ __ ] things but somebody hacks
somebody's phone there are text messages
or their emails that's none of my
[ __ ] business man I I really can't
believe like what [ __ ] Boyer's people
are I don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
does you know I don't give a [ __ ] what
you said on your phone and I think if
you know like if somebody have it like
oh can you believe this person texted
this this is offensive it's like well
they didn't text it to you they text it
privately to somebody else you're not
supposed to be reading that don't read
other people's text messages you won't
get [ __ ] offended you have no idea
what the tone of that was this could be
a joke this could be dead Syria no
[ __ ] idea and even still it's like
reading some but I love about reading
somebody else's mail is [ __ ] illegal
but like hacking somebody's phone is
fine I have no idea anyways I guess the
only part that I thought you might have
changed your mind on is how people
around the world have heard you cuz they
got it illegally listening to your
podcast helps me sort out my feelings on
lots of things but also your points make
me realize that the world has virtually
no black or white issues well if you
talk about my podcast my podcast is free
but I would say as it changed yeah I
still pay for music I go to iTunes is
where I do it I don't like those
streaming services because they [ __ ]
over the musicians and I know Apple
iTunes they just [ __ ] them over man it's
ridiculous iTunes does it too like I
know like one of them I remember they
were talking about least possibly
streaming like one of my albums they're
like yeah for every thousand plays will
give you will give you a half a cent
it's like [ __ ] yourself they had all
this advertising and [ __ ] on the side
and everything so they're getting all
this credit and making all this [ __ ]
money and then
even rolling a penny towards me they're
chopping it in half and then sliding it
across the [ __ ] table I will say like
you know I don't police a lot of [ __ ]
too much on YouTube I should probably do
that more but you know I definitely saw
the advantages you know when I went to
when I went over to Europe I gave up my
DVDs for free and told people to upload
them on to their YouTube pages because I
wanted to get into the you know
different language areas on YouTube you
know because I want time I was trying to
learn to play at the rhythm diverse
section of Walk This Way on the good on
the guitar and the only guy did a lesson
was a French guy and I clicked on his
[ __ ] video and then all of a sudden
all my videos to the right were in
French and I was like wow what part of
YouTube is this so when I went to Norway
and Sweden and all those I was like you
know put clips of this up on your page I
don't give a [ __ ] you know it's on
Pirate Bay anyways what the [ __ ] do I
care I might as well get in on this
somehow so I kind of had to roll with it
but you know I it's it's still stealing
but I pay for all my movies I pay for uh
well that isn't necessarily true
there'll be a few like I try I try to
pay for movies like if I go on like
Netflix and it isn't there and I can't
find it
playing on cable you know and it's
something I really want to [ __ ] see I
will watch a movie for free I'll admit
that I definitely done that [ __ ] you
know what sucks is one of the [ __ ]
movies I can't even remember the name of
the movie and I've really [ __ ]
enjoyed it um [ __ ] what the hell was
that yeah I literally watched its Oh
something was it gringo set the name of
the [ __ ] movie Charlize Theron was in
it and she was [ __ ] hilarious and her
character was was [ __ ] I loved the
movie
absolutely love the movie um let's see
gringo Charlize Theron right is that the
name of the movie did I get it right
yeah gringo check that one out love that
movie and then I saw [ __ ] I got an
answer this hanger alright I'm back
so anyways then I watched this other
movie called super fly and was [ __ ]
blown away like I couldn't get the
[ __ ] all the actors names and there
was so many great actors and there was
this kid I hope they say his name it
it's kaal a and kr Walker Kalon Kalon I
hope I say it right k ry to [ __ ]
white to get it right Walker his
character was so [ __ ] good I don't
want to ruin the movie I just thought
the last time you saw should have been
more of an event with how good his
performance was and then the kid who
played super flies right-hand man was
[ __ ] great I I don't know how to do
this without ruining the [ __ ] movie
there's Sony it's just it's a really fun
[ __ ] movie I've seen some good ones
lately but uh you know I'm writing this
[ __ ] script I got in the whole world
of writing scripts now so now I'm
actually watching movies I'm trying to
find people just remember him oh they
were in in gringo that the [ __ ] dude
who played the guys accountant in the
beginning was [ __ ] great
everybody that movie was great so check
those up man I hope I'm not doing this
[ __ ] where I saw it on a plane so you're
just like this is [ __ ] great it's
taking up two and a half hours but these
were legit good fight I think they'll
hold up even if you're just hanging out
at your house you know with your [ __ ]
virtual reality glasses and whatever the
[ __ ] internet porn you're watching I
think you can get through them alright
those are my recommendations for movies
congratulations to the [ __ ] Lions man
a huge huge [ __ ] victory for you guys
you turn around
I'm liking seeing you know the Chiefs
and all these these teams being I mean I
obviously don't want the Patriots run to
ever [ __ ] end and I've enjoyed the
hell out of it and you know I remember
coming
was all about the Cowboys and Steelers
and I remember thinking when the [ __ ]
our time and so when we finally had our
time I enjoyed the whole thing I hope
it's not over but if it is you know it
[ __ ] is and I'll be happy for the
rest of my [ __ ] life is why me what
am I gonna do I'm gonna [ __ ] about
[ __ ] 10 11 Championships straight
across the [ __ ] board and a 15 year
period it was incredible but the Red Sox
are still coming you know who knows good
key could keep going on Celtics look
[ __ ] good I still believe in the
Patriots though but it is a lot of fun
to see all these different teams doing
well and I'm like beyond excited to see
the next Browns game because I want to
see this Baker Mayfield kids see if he
likes it up again it's exciting all
right that's it that's the podcast have
a great couple of days I'll check yeah
on Thursday go [ __ ] yourselves